Did English Speakers Really Not Use Contractions
in the 19th Century as Depicted in True Grit?
Won’t, don’t, wouldn’t, isn’t and
even ain’t- where would we be without our
contractions?
Prevalent in spoken English and increasingly
accepted in written pieces, contractions enable
brevity and make written works more accessible
and friendly.
Contractions in some form of English date
back to Old English (450 AD – 1150 AD),
a language that bears little resemblance to
our English today.
Before this period, although the Romans had
already invaded, the dominant language on
the island was Celtic.
In the 5th century, several groups, notably
the Angles and the Saxons, began to invade,
and they brought their Germanic languages
and rune alphabets with them, along with several
well-established contractions.
These included shortened forms for “is not”
(nis, today, “isn’t”), “did not have”
(ne haefde), “was not” (ne waes, today
“wasn’t”) and “would not” (wolde,
today “wouldn’t).
During the Old English period, Christian missionaries
introduced Latin as well as the Roman alphabet,
so by the time the Normans appeared in the
mid-11th century, the language was ready to
incorporate a fair bit of French, the language
of post-Conquest English nobility.
(In fact, King Richard “The Lionheart”
barely spoke English, and only spent about
six months in the country he was king of for
the decade he was king.)
Nonetheless, the common people continued to
speak English, although now peppered with
thousands of French words and conventions,
and eventually, this pidgin developed into
Middle English (1150 AD to 1450 AD).
Far easier for a modern English speaker to
understand, it was during this period that
negative contractions (i.e. using “not”)
arrived on the scene in the form of ne were
(“were not”) and noot (“knows not”).
Other contractions from this period include
thilke (for “the ilke” meaning “the
same”) and sit (a shortened form of sitteth).
By the turn of the 16th century, the Renaissance
arrived in England and with it came further
changes to the language, which by this time
is recognizable as Early Modern English (1450
AD to 1750 AD).
Latin and Greek words were adopted and altered
(e.g., militia, squalor, illicit and explain),
and men like Shakespeare were introducing
new words to the masses at a rapid pace (e.g.,
assassination, cold-blooded, eyeball and fashionable).
Some contractions that appear during the Early
Middle English period include I’ll (I will),
‘twould (it would) and ’twill (it will),
as well as negative contractions of every
form including can’t (cannot), don’t (do
not), shan’t (shall not), mayn’t (may
not)and won’t (will not).
According to the Online Etymology Dictionary,
won’t first appeared at the dawn of the
period in the mid-15th century as wynnot and
then wonnot, and its modern form in the mid-17th
century.
Don’t was first recorded in the 1630s, and
can’t first appeared in print in 1706.
Ain’t also first appeared in 1706 as a contraction
only for “am not,” although by the early
1800s, it was also used to mean a variety
of negatives including “are not,” “is
not,” “have not,” and “has not.”
As you might have guessed from all this, contrary
to what the latest True Grit film would seem
to indicate, contractions were around long
before Mattie and Rooster were attempting
to avenge her father.
However, during the period in which the character
of Mattie was off on her adventure (1880s),
in formal writing contractions were absolutely
disfavored.
This is a trend that started in earnest around
the late 18th century.
However, as we can see by the works of Mark
Twain (1835-1910), among many others who wrote
certain characters speaking the way real people
actually talked in this era, in everyday speech,
contractions seemed to have been the norm.
So why did the Coen brothers choose not to
use them in their adaptation of the True Grit
serials?
Ethan Coen explained in an interview, “We’ve
been told that the language and all that formality
is faithful to how people talked in the period.”
While this is mostly true in formal writing,
it was most definitely not in common speech,
particularly for characters like Rooster Cogburn
and Tom Chaney.
And, in truth, the original True Grit serials,
written in 1968 from the perspective of a
woman writing in the 1920s, used “won’t”
instead of “will not” about 36% of the
time and “don’t” instead of “do not”
about 60% of the time, among other uses of
contractions.
As for today, despite the many years contractions
have been taboo in formal writing, as with
many grammatical sacred cows, time (starting
around the 1920s) and more recently the Internet
seems to have changed at least some people’s
views of their acceptability in writing.
Nonetheless, apparently the APA still disapproves
of them, according to many commentators, and
the United Kingdom’s The Guardian newspaper
cautions against overusing many contractions
including can’t, aren’t, don’t, I’m
and it’s even though “they might make
a piece . . . easier to read, they can be
an irritant and a distraction, and make a
serious article sound frivolous.”
On the other hand, reference guides for AP
style note that contractions found in reputable
dictionaries are acceptable in informal writing,
but should not be used excessively, and the
Chicago Manual of Style goes further to say
that “most types of writing benefit from
the use of contractions,” although they
should be used “thoughtfully.”
Experts in business writing generally approve
of the use of contractions for creating a
flowing style that engages the reader, but
warn that when writing for an international
audience where there will be non-native English
speakers, contractions can be confusing and
should be avoided.
Uncle Sam has even weighed in on the debate.
Beginning in 1998 when President Bill Clinton
issued an executive memo instructing federal
agencies to write more plainly, the federal
government has been trying to turn government
jargon into readable English.
Along with the 2010 Plain Writing Act signed
into law by President Obama, these two directives
have resulted in PlainLanguage.gov, a set
of instructions for government employees to
help them write documents Americans will understand.
Under these guidelines, writers are instructed
to “use contractions when appropriate,”
even with legal writing as they will render
it “less stuffy and more natural.”
To sum it up, the directive is “write as
you talk,” but use discretion when including
contractions.